Why are all these people wearing red?
We wear red because we care.
We wear red because we love our heart.
SMU joins companies across America to support the American Heart Association's Go Red for Women movement...
...by celebrating National Wear Red day.
This year's event was held on Friday, February 5th,...
...where more than 175 SMU students, staff and faculty gathered on the steps of Dallas Hall to show their support.
SMU is supporting us in educating our young students.
Hopefully getting to them sooner, rather than later, to educate them about the importance of having a healthy heart.
Heart disease is the leading cause of death in women.
It kills over 432,000 women each year.
That ends up being about one woman every minute.
Yet studies show that only 21 percent of women view heart disease as their greatest threat even more than cancer.
I think it's important because you really need to get the word out...
...and we've made so much progress that it's kind of sad if we don't get the word out since we know so much information at this point.
So we don't want that to be the reason why people suffer...
...just because they didn't get the knowledge or the information that's widely available for everyone.
SMU supports Go Red for Women.